언제 공실이 있는지 몇 년 동안
공실이 있는지이 부분을 확인하실 수
[음악]
있습니다네 안녕하세요 빌사남 어 제가
오늘은 부동산 투자할 때 여러분들
지도를 많이 보시잖아요 이제 로드뷰를
많이 보는데 로드뷰를 볼 때 연도별로
히스토리 보는 부분이 되게
중요합니다데 아마 모르시는 분들이
있어서이 영상을 좀 찍어 보도록
하겠습니다 네이버지도 같은 경우에는
2010년부터 서비스를 시작을 해서
그 그때 이후로 이제 로드뷰가 나와요
지금 카카오 맵 2008년부터 시작을
해 가지고 네이버보다 더 일찍 시작을
했습니다 그래서 만약에 2008년과
보고 싶다라고 하면 지금 카카오맵
로드뷰를 보시면 될 거 같습니다
연도별 히스토리를 왜 말씀드리면 이게
굉장히 좀 중요하거든요 그래서
여러분들이 빌딩 투자할 때 반드시
봐야 되는 어 그런 부분입니다 연도별
히스토리를 보는 이유가 두 가지가
있습니다 우선 첫 번째로 연도별로
공실 내역을 확인할 수 있어요 언 제
공실이 몇 년 동안 공실이 있는지이
부분을 확인하실 수 있습니다 제가
예시로 한번 좀 보여 드릴게요 지금이
건물입니다요 건물이고 원래 이제
2019년도에 매입을 했어요 여러분들
지나다니다 보면 이렇게 차에 이렇게
카메라 붙어 있는 거 있거든요 그게
이제 촬영하는 거예요 2010년도부터
이렇게 쭉 저장이 되어 있고
19년도에 보면은 되게 유명한 화장품
업체가 들어와 있고 임대 수익이
굉장히 좀 잘 나오는 건물이었습니다
근데 2019년도에 사자 자 20년도
5월 달에 로드뷰를 보면은 공실이
됐어요 21년도도 보면 21년도도
공실
22년도도 공실
23년도도 공실
24년도도 공실입니다 그래서 보시는
거와 같이 5년 동안 공실이 있어요
그래서 여러분들이 이렇게 연도별로
로드뷰를 보셔야 돼요 아 여기가
임대가 좀 잘 안 되는 곳이구나
그렇게 좀 파악이 가능하거든요 반드시
연도별로 좀 파악을 해야 된다 그게
첫 번째고 두 번째로는 리모델링이나
신축 전후 모습을 확인할 수 있습니다
그래서 그 전후 모습을 확인해서
건물이 어떻게 바는 바뀌었는지 어
로드뷰를 통해서 확인을 할 수 있고
이거는 좀 부동산 교육 측면에서 되게
중요한 부분 같아요이 전후 모습을 좀
보셔야지 나중에 건물을 어떻게
개발해야 될지가 좀 머릿속에
그려지거나 내가 신축이나 리모델링을
생각 중이다고 하면 연도별 히스토리를
더 어 보셔야 됩니다 현장 가서
보는게 제일 좋겠지만 편하게 이제
클릭해서 전의 모습도 볼 수 있기
때문에이 히스토리를 알면 나중에
여러분들이 그런 낡은 건물을 봤을 때
어떻게 바꿔야 겠다라는게 머릿속에 좀
그려지게 됩니다네 그래서 여러분들
이런 연도별 히스토리를 좀 반드시
보셨으면 좋겠습니다 첫 번째로 공실
기간 그리고 전모습 이런 걸 좀
확인할 수 있고 여러분들 부동산 투자
교육하게이 연도별 히스토리의 그
로드뷰가 되게 좀 도움이 많이 될
거라는 거 좀 말씀드렸습니다 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]